hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar nanoscopy
meets lifetime
introducing the new stellaris eight
taustead i'm alexis cross of labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by labyrinths
and sponsored by leica microsystems for
more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
leicamicrosystems.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen i
would like to welcome back i would like
to welcome our presenter
dr julia roberti product manager at
advanced
confocal imaging for a complete
biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr
berry you may now begin your
presentation
welcome
thank you and thank you all for being
here today
my name is julia roberti i'm product
manager for advanced confocal imaging
and i'm absolutely thrilled to share
with you today an overview of our latest
innovations in super resolution and
dynoscopy
with the stellaristet and stellaris
eight-step
microscopes and let me start very
quickly with this question why stat
super resolution why
do we choose this technology and
integrate it in our
new uh stellaris confocal platform and
i found this a very nice quote by a
member of the nobel committee
on the occasion of the nobel prize in
chemistry 2014
and when we want to do stat
we want to get quantitative descriptions
at the nanoscale
of the dynamics of complex molecular
biology
processes that define the phenotypes of
all life forms
and this means that we can go way below
the
diffraction limit with molecular
specificity
to study structure and dynamic
interactions and we can reach
this level of detail that is not um
achievable with um conventional
far-field flows and microscopy
and not only that we can access
information on these structures within
the context of
cells tissue and organisms
and with this motivation in mind now i
want to go further and show you how we
have
reimagined super resolution with our two
microscopes
the stellaristed and the stellaris eight
stat
and how did we do this well we took
advantage of the strengths
of our new confocal platform that we
developed to have
the power to see more to gather more
signal and get
get the best and optimal images from
every specimen
having access to the lifetime based
information with every
experiment and having the means to do
more with tools that integrate
very powerfully and nicely all these
aspects
and for stead this means that
we can understand molecular
relationships and mechanisms
within the cellular context following
multiple events at a time
we can obtain outstanding super
resolution and image quality
combined with sample protection thanks
to a new way of doing stats
and we can get access to stead with an
easy setup of experiments in a few
clicks for first time
users and with full control for expert
microscopists
and i want to share with you now an
example
very nice of in which we characterize a
transcription
regulation uh with single molecule fish
so
this is a three color tausted image of
drosophila embryo whole mount where the
probes are not amplified
and we can see very nicely that with
cofocal we can get
an excellent image of the entire embryo
and then we can choose a region of
interest and we can
study it and we can go nicely from the
confocal information to toast it in
three colors
and access the information on the three
genes targeted in this case
with molecular specificity and at
nanoscopy
resolution and as i mentioned one of the
ingredients to achieve this as
as i said is the ability to see more and
for stat this means that we can extend
the number of simultaneous event to
study
thanks to the flexible use and
combination of statistical floral force
we can find the best imaging conditions
for the sample
thanks to the flexibility of three step
laser lines and we can obtain
excellent image quality
thanks to the new power id family of
highly sensitive
photon counting capable detectors
so um with stellaris and instead on
stellaris
we achieve this by the combination of
the power height detectors
the new white laser the newly optimized
beam path for
optimized transmission and as i
mentioned up to three state lines and
here we have
another example on multicolored stat
imaging in which we can
uh go very nicely from confocal
to nanoscopy resolution in this case by
targeting
a nuclear pores mitochondria and actin
so in stead for stellaris
we have as a first new thing i want to
share with you
the new power id detector family i will
not go into detail because of time but
for sure we can discuss that later
and i would also point you to our uh
newly uh published application note in
nature methods
that describes and where you can find
details uh
more details about this new family of
detectors
and for stat this means that we have up
to five state capable
fast and sensitive photon counting
detectors
and we combine these detectors with
a new thing uh in provided by stellaris
which is the next
generation white light lasers and here
uh if you're familiar with the white
light laser and
aovs technology uh you know that with a
single laser we can do the work of many
and we can
combine up to eight single excitation
lines simultaneously
and we will have four stead available to
the two types of white light laser that
we offer with different excitation range
possibilities
from 485 to 685 and from 440
to 790 and with this we get complete
spectral freedom
with excitation optimally matched to the
floor for
and so we have uh everything covered
from the white light laser
aobs beam path size uh side with
the power id detectors and we complement
and we round that
up with the three stat lines available
to cover the entire spectrum
so that we can optimize for best
performance of suitable floor force
we can do a 3d stat and for this we can
select the dimension we need
with our proven technology which is
robust and easy to use
and it allows us to allocate the light
to two-step uh pathways to get the best
lateral resolution
or the best best axial resolution or
tune between uh
between them and optimize for the
smallest focal volume
and when we talk about a 3d stead of
course we need to consider and take care
of the inhomogeneities for example the
cover glass thickness
temperature changes refractive index
mismatch
that becomes significant when we go deep
and for this we have
the statewide class of object objective
lenses
with best in class optics for stat
imaging so we can have the best
starting point and we can adaptively
correct at the sample level
where these sources of aberrations occur
and
we have three stead specialized lenses
for daily
for deep and for life cell nanoscopy
so now i want to move on to the next
very exciting
aspect which goes into the direction of
what lifetime based information brings
into the stat
world and with this we will be able to
perform
stat imaging at cutting edge resolution
with excellent quality and dramatically
light dose and dramatically lower lidos
we will be able to perform extended
stead imaging experiments
at gentle conditions and that means more
frames for dynamic lifestyle experiments
or volumetric imaging and we will have
access to stat imaging with the best
steadflora force especially in the far
red range
that overlap spectrally thanks to
lifetime based
species separation and this is uh thanks
to a new way of doing instead with the
technology that we developed and it's
called
tousted and with lifetime based species
separation
so i have here an example that
illustrates exactly what is the strength
of
taustead i have here nuclear pores that
i
we have stained at the basket so then
you see a tiny dots where the pores are
and we image them in confocal and also
instead with
very very low light dose extremely low
so with two percent
of our 660 uh stead line and if you
compare the confocal with the
conventional state we don't see
much of a difference or benefit but
having access to towsted we can see now
that
protecting the sample because we are
talking about a really
low steady light we can achieve
outstanding
stat quality and resolution
so now i want to explain to you a bit
more in detail how it works and for that
i want to start with lifetime so
fluorescence lifetime
makes its appearance and if we think how
the fluorescence emission process uh
occurs
we have molecules in a ground state and
they are excited
and they come back from the excited
state back to the
uh ground state by different processes
and when this process is the emission of
photons then we are talking about
fluorescence
and we will be able to count the number
of a number of photons and that
corresponds to the intensity of
fluorescence that we measure but
also there's a very important um
parameter there's a very important
aspect which is
the time that it takes for the molecules
to come back from the excited state to
the ground state
and this average time is exactly the
fluorescence
lifetime we can measure it in our system
because we have wildlife laser will
pulse
excitation and we have photon counting
detectors so basically what we will do
is we will
measure the time that it takes for the
photons to be detected
and with this this information we can
estimate and we can calculate
the um the lifetime the fluorescence
lifetime
and that means that in an experiment in
which we have
a flame capability so we have access to
fluorescence lifetime imaging microscopy
we will get not only the intensity
information but
we will also get flame information and
we will get
this extra layer that will allows us to
get more from the stat side
and this technology flame it's very
powerful because the fluorescent's
lifetime depends on the micro
environment
and on one hand it opens the door for
molecular interaction doing
a fling threat biosensing based on
probes that can
exhibit changes in lifetime and also we
can do
lifetime based structure or fluorophore
or species separation
and flim is so powerful because
the fluorescence lifetime gives feedback
from competing processes
so if we have uh processes that can
bring back the molecules to the ground
state
other than emission then the
fluorescence lifetime will
sense these processes and then it will
change
and now nanoscopy comes to play because
exactly
stat is a competing process so if we
have
access to the fluorescence lifetime
information when we have a stat
process when stead is occurring we will
see it in fluorescence lifetime changes
and this is the basis of the technology
that allows us to
look at instead from a different point
of view
so what do we see when we do a
traditional stead and what do we see
when we do stat
combined with lifetime imaging so in the
case of intensity based
stead we have our excitation and we have
the stead donut overlaid and then we
will get an intensity bait
based uh effective psf but there's more
information as i've
mentioned we have the uh
lifetime information and if we can
access to this information we will be
able to map
the state psf together with not only the
intensity but also this lifetime
information so we generate a tau coded
stat psf and we can do that point by
point on our scanning point in our
experiment and the lifetime information
will reveal
crucial details for estate experiment
because we will have not only the
excitation and the stat
donut information we will have
information on the maximum
and minimal energy that the fluorophores
are
sensing and using the lifetime
information we will be able to tune the
resolution
and also we will be able to identify
photons that are not associated with the
step process
but come from uncorrelated
signal and so we will be able to take
care of the background
and all based on the photophysical
information that we get
in our experiments and so
we have developed a towsted and to
explain you
uh how we have implemented as i
mentioned we need access to
flame information and we will not do it
in a fitting way so we will do it
accessing phasor flame analysis i will
not
explain all in detail how phasers work
but so that you get an idea
this is how a flim information looks
when you
analyze and you put it in a phaser uh
interface
plot and this corresponds this cluster
you see here corresponds to the lifetime
information that i get in this case
from the knob sample in confocal mode
and as i mentioned uh stead will compete
with the fluorescence lifetime of the
normal emission of the floral force so
when i
activate stat you will see now here
in the in the phasor that the cluster
moves
and the cluster moves to a different set
and a different trajectory of lifetimes
because of the stat
effect and we will use this to generate
our thousand
image so we will collect fast the
lifetime
information at each scanning point of
the state acquisition
and uh using the the phasor analysis
we will focus and we will use the stead
information the state trajectory
to generate the information that comes
from the center of the donut and
identify the
information that comes from the crest of
the donut and also we will have
information and access to
the background information that is
located in all this region
of the phaser and we will do a
correlation
of the each um each uh
point with the state uh trajectory to
decide if the information we are seeing
is background or not
and we will obtain the toasted image
online and in an automated
way so pressing background increasing
the image quality and the resolution at
lower
uh lighthouse and this is totally
integrated and
automated in our elastic software in the
image compass
user interface and it's accessible one
click away and how do tau state images
look like well
so if we go back to our knob sample
we can see the increase in resolution
and uh
the signal to noise that we can obtain
when we generate the tau state
uh databusted image and we can even
push the resolution for example using in
this case
um the gatapeats um containing ato
647n and they have a nominal size of 23
nanometer
and when we do a taostat experiment at
775
uh with a stat 775 we can get resolution
better than
a 30 nanometer so we can really push the
resolution
but not only that so we can do it in a
2d in 3d and in multi-color and to show
you
an example and this is two color
to the stats of glomerular components in
mouse kidney that have been stained for
synaptopodine and nephron and you can
see
very nicely how can we can distinguish
this intricate
uh structure that especially in a mouse
kidney
uncle it's very compact and very
challenging to
extract using super resolution but with
taustead we can do it
very easily and very nicely and as i
mentioned it works for multi-color
applications
in 2d and 3d
a third aspect and a third key
application is the possibility to
access to stat imaging conditions in
gentle
in a gentle regime and then do
lifestyle experiments in dynamic
conditions
so first i want to share with you this
very nice example of
life hela cells stained with silicon
rhodamine tubulin
and we applied a very low
light of the state 775 laser and as you
see we can get
resolution of the microtubules before
below 50 nanometer
in gentle conditions so we can protect
our sample
and then perform extended uh time-lapse
imaging
and uh this we can see very nicely here
where we have a towsted experiment with
the stead 592
line and we managed to get over 200
frames at one frame per second
at low stead power and uh we can
characterize very nicely
in this case actin filaments that are
stained with em neon green
and i want to mention that uh for
stellaris we have uh
as new features a pso stage for
increased
z stability and also we have auto focus
control for confocal instead for
workflows for all our
three us deadlines available so
we can open the door for this type of
highly dynamic lifestyle
applications and uh as a
last uh very nice example of what you
can do
when you have access to lifetime
information and in this case we are
using flame phasers
in stellaris eight stead falcon i
want to show you what you can do with it
so here we have hex cells that have been
stained with
bimensin and actin using alexa 647 and
alto 647n
and as you uh know um they overlap
in the farad region of the spectrum so
if we collect
with a single detection channel we will
get if we only use the intensity
information in confocal or
instead we will only get both structures
mixed and we cannot do much more
than this we get the super resolution
the nanoscopy detail but the structures
we cannot distinguish
so i want to show you now how having
lifetime based information
allows us to separate these structures
and do the species separation
and we do that using uh flame phasers
and um the phasers are here
so this corresponds to the confocal that
i'm not showing uh
in in this slide when we have the stat
trajectory with
both what both species contributing
we can select the individual
contributions and using the algebra of
phasors
the system automatically will generate
from
one intensity channel it will generate
two
channels in which we will have the
information of the by mentioning
and acting very nicely separated
so now we can think of expanding the
number of species
image using lifetime based information
and even combining
uh so this very nice and stable far red
fluorophores for step so to summarize
this tau stat chapter with a toasted
we can improve image quality and
resolution at low light dose
we can perform gentle lifestyle stead
for extended time-lapse
imaging we can identify and eliminate
uncorrelated background
and investigate protein protein
interaction with multi-colors test
step based on lifetime separation so we
are opening the door to new insights
into structure and function
and uh very importantly you get all the
raw data so then you can go back
to the to the raw data and then you can
validate
your results uh before i
finish my presentation i want to mention
this uh third
aspect so how can we achieve more with
stead on stellaris
and uh in the case of stead this means
that we can
get results that we can trust thanks to
the guided acquisition
using image compass that is centered on
your sample characteristics
so in the same way as you would set up a
confocal experiment dragon
zoom drag and drop of the fluorophores
that you know you have in your sample
we have incorporated the state
information so you drag and drop and you
immediately
can uh with um one click and start of
the experiment
then you can get the appropriate state
line that goes with that fluorophore and
conditions that will allow you to get a
very good
stat image right away and then you can
find you can
optimize and find you fine tune further
you can also improve the workflow with
the fastest stat acquisition in the
market
because we have a fast system there with
1.5 nanoseconds that time
and we can have that advantageously used
for lifestyle imaging and we can
validate the results
because we have the availability of stat
modality
confocal we can do super resolution with
lightning and we can also
apply thousands tools with stellaris and
this is fully
integrated with stat in our new platform
so um to finish i want to show you
a brief overview of how our product
portfolio looks like
so as i mentioned we have two systems
thus their estet
and the stellaris eight stat the stellar
stead comes equipped with
a white light laser that is uh offering
a range for excitation with lines from
a485 to 685
and it has a high ds and high dx
available
and for stellaris eight stead we have a
full power offstat on the
stellaris eight with the possibilities
of different modalities
uh that we can upgrade and stereois
eight stat
has available tousted when it has a
falcon
in available and as i mentioned we have
up to five power ids available we have
improved signal
thanks to the new white light laser with
uh the power ids and the optimized beam
path
we have uh toasted with all the benefits
that we have
um that we have seen
we have also thousands tools for stead
that allows for example
ultra flexible digital gating with up to
16 digital gates
on the fly and we have the piezo stage
and the autofocus control and finally
everything is
increment implemented in the image
compass user interface
so with this i would like to thank you
for your attention
and i will very happily take your
questions
thank you very much
thank you dr verified for your
informative presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so dr roberti let's get started with our
first question
do you use the split matrix method to
separate components
using isat in your slider or do you use
your own
phaser cloud separation or edit method
and if so what formal formula do you use
ah thank you this is a very nice
question
so of course there there were um reports
already
in literature using and exploiting the
phaser
approach for stead and
we took that as inspiration for our
development and our technology but our
approach for thousands using the
lifetime information
and the phasers is a proprietary and uh
so we are not using split
and uh for those familiar with the with
the split approach
for doing split you need the confocal
information together with the step
information
that is something that we don't need for
towsted so we figure out
and we do our um so our approach
with the information that comes from the
instead from the state experiment
alone and with that it's enough so
basically with all the information that
we collect
we can define what is the maximum and
minimum
energy that our fluorophores our probes
are seen
and using that information we use that
to do a correlation
to assign uh the different uh photons
coming as
coming from background and uncorrelated
signal or coming from the stat process
and also to construct a step trajectory
on the phaser
and then produce the the image that has
a
tunable resolution
thank you so much for that answer dr
rarity so moving on to our next question
how deep into tissue sections can you
typically achieve
super resolution for example using
vibrate sections of fixed brain tissue
um so for doing deep nanoscopy
our approach is using um adaptive
corrections
using a motorized uh collar uh on our
specialized stat objective lenses the
stat white
objectives that are corrected
so superbly corrected for uh spherical
aberrations like
chromatic aberrations uh and uh
tuning so it's very important to match
the refraction index
as uh much as possible to the immersion
medium that
in the case of our deep uh nanoscopy
objective lens is a glycerol lens uh
and i would say that when the refraction
index is uh
very well matched you can reach depth of
we have done in our experiments on
kidney samples for example 175
micrometer deep so it takes
um optimization from the sample point of
view but that is something that
anyway when you want to go deep you need
to take care of
uh but then using the our um
motorized uh collar then that's
something that is uh
achievable
wonderful we want to thank our audience
for all of these great questions coming
in
so moving on to our next one what is the
longest time lapse that have been
recorded
so far and at what sampling interval
um so we have
examples on live cells um
and what i showed here is something so
it's a time lapse of over
200 frames so we had 230 frames
uh we also have imaging on mitochondria
live cells over 300 frames
so it really depends on what is the
process that
yeah that is observed
and the sampling interval in principle
the advantage
of uh of our system is that you can
image pretty fast and as our detectors
and our system in in as a whole
has a very short uh dead time
then we can collect a lot of photons uh
and in principle you can do
something like one frame per second i is
and of course you can you can go faster
if
if you need so as a real example we have
examples yes of one frame per second
uh for a 1k 1k um
image and yeah so we have image
300 frames that would be our
in-house best mark
wonderful thank you so much i do want to
remind our audience that any questions
that we are unable to answer today and
those that come in during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by dr roberti via the
email address that you provided
when you registered for this event so
our next
question is there any possibility that
we can use this system for flimfret
measurement
[Music]
yes of course so our uh platform
comes so when you have uh the asterisk
eight
with stead and with falcon then you have
a fully fledged confocal system that is
capable of doing uh flim in
uh our falcon way so very fast so you
can do flame at uh confocal speed
and uh you can do flim fret uh
experiment
if you're talking about doing flim fret
and stat that is of course technically
possible so you have a
microscope that is capable of doing that
then
uh i would say from an application point
of view it's something
quite complex uh but in principle you
have the
platform and you have the microscope on
which you can
design your experiments and and perform
it
wonderful thank you so um here's another
question for us
regarding the 3d analyzing of stead
i wonder if we have cells if we were to
have cells on a 3d
platform for example hydrogel what would
be the
maximum distance from objective to
sample
that allows us to do stead
um so this again is
is a question that requires
to match the reflection
index of your sample and our objectives
uh in principles the working distance of
our
two stead lenses for deep
applications uh the glycerol and the
water lens is 300 micron
so then it's a matter of uh
matching the refraction index so then
you can
uh you can get uh excellent performance
on your measurements
so um as i mentioned we have
um good experiences going over 100
micron
um so yeah but in this particular case i
i have not
uh done experiments on um this kind of
uh
gels so it's something that would be
um yeah so we would need to to bring a
sample to the system and
and and try
thank you dr verdi so it looks like we
have time for a few more questions
so does taosted work with all steadlines
yes so uh we can apply uh our towsted
approach with the three
stat lines that we offer uh the 592
the 660 and the 775. so in principle you
have
all the flexibility for working with
different fluorophores in the
from the green to the thyroid region of
the spectrum
thank you now does the lifetime
separation of
overlapping fluorophores allow one to do
multi-color
life cells stead faster than spectrally
separating fluorophores
so
let me think about that
um
i would say this
in principle the so if you want to do
lifetime
based separation you will collect so it
depends on how many photons you are
collecting
um we are pretty fast
on uh with our system so we can do flame
imaging at confocal speed uh
so you could have it so you could do it
as you
acquire the images um
and yeah so in principle i would say
that it would be
comparable to um spectral separation
approach so you would not um
have um a disadvantage
let's say so trying to get from uh
from a flame to as opposed to a spectral
um point of view as long as you have
enough photons so that is something that
is
depending on the on the fluorophores
so again it's a matter of
of preparing the sample and uh and
experiment with it
so in principle this so for um these
flame based
uh approaches we are so it's a
sample dependent so you need to
to try and and see how the particular
fluorophore combination that you have
chosen works
thank you dr rarity for that
clarification and so moving on to our
next question
so what is the typical resolution
achieved in
living cells by taustead
so let's see
um considering the samples that we have
uh that we have with which we have
experience on on toustet
um i really like the
the results that we have obtained um
labeling tubulin for example
um with um sir tubulin which is a very
nice uh
option for uh industry so for tagging uh
live cells uh with uh with a probe that
is very
very small and fluorogenic and uh
there i we could get 45 nanometer
on the microtubules in living cells
which i
would say it's an excellent uh an
excellent number for resolution
so again here um
it depends so if you really need to go
very
very fast then you may
have to sacrifice a bit of signal
so then you would be
doing some balancing between resolution
and speed
but in principle um you can get
excellent
results so it's really you you can push
the the resolution
also at uh low light lows so this is
this tubulin is the example that was
shown
sorry was shown on the presentation and
we were working with uh
10 of the of the stat
775 laser
wonderful thank you so much and it looks
like we have time for maybe one more
question
so okay can i use taustead for stead
3d applications
yes sure so the approach that we
that we uh implemented works for
2d and for 3d so basically from the
lifetime information that we are
collecting we can get
benefits in terms in terms of the
background
removal and on the resolution
improvement in
uh in the three dimensions for four
steps
thank you again dr berdy do you have any
final comments for our audience
i thank you very much for your attention
and
if you have any uh doubts any questions
then you can reach me on my email
so you can contact us and
i will be happy to discuss your
particular application
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their
really interesting questions that came
in so questions that we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr dr
roberti for her time today
and her important research we would also
like to thank labbert and our sponsor
leica microsystems for underwriting
today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us everyone
and until next time bye bye everyone